I really don't like to be told what to
do Gary thanks for talking with us well
thank you for thank you for talking with
me you have just started a initiative a
nonprofit called our America initiative
what what is our America well so 501 C 4
which is an committee as honorary
chairman of that committee the I get to
speak out on the issues of the day we
get to raise money and speak out on the
issues of the day and so I'm really
excited about it there's been a lot of
interest and I got out of office I
really purposefully didn't want to have
an opinion on everything that was going
on because I feel like from a political
standpoint that individuals should get
involved and then get out you were
governor of new mexico from 1994 to 2002
you were reelected and then term-limited
out for a third consecutive term well
being a firm believer in term limits
maybe I wouldn't have been reelected and
term limits really I think as a result
of term limits politicians do things
that they might not otherwise have done
and maybe I wouldn't have been as a bold
if you want to say that what were to say
what were your three big accomplishments
as governor of New Mexico well first of
all I think that I really did a good job
when it came to controlling the growth
of state government I would have vetoed
vetoed 750 bills while I was governor of
new mexico i would have had thousands of
line items as governor of new mexico
putting that into perspective that was
like almost more than the other 49
governors in the country combined New
Mexico's 221 Democrat I got elected as a
Republican but by saying no to state
spending and I say KN 0 W by saying KN 0
w 22 what government should and
shouldn't do I think really did it did a
great job of showing people that
government
government doesn't have to spend money
to make you happy that government really
needs to be providing level playing
field what what was one of the areas
where you cut spending or got government
out of business altogether really it was
it was a across the board I mean it was
about best product best service lowest
price so without exception I think that
that happened over an eight-year period
in New Mexico while I was governor the
number of state employees excluding
education went from 13,000 to 12,000 so
a thousand person reduction in state
government over an eight-year period
that had never happened before and that
just from a common-sense standpoint
would tell you that government was more
efficient because I'm going to argue we
did more with with less people that
that's good government and that's what
happened now since I've left office my
successor has taken that number from
12,000 now to 16,500 I argue no area of
state and government of state government
has been improved and yet there's been
that many more employees added at a cost
of back of my napkin a couple hundred
million bucks factoring in benefits
you're basically exploring the idea of
running for president in 2012 why well
actually as part of the 501 C 4 I can't
comment on that I can't say that I have
any interest in running for federal
office how these issues will resonate
again rather than sitting on the couch
and wondering how these issues might
resonate this 501 C 4 our America
initiative dot-com is allowing me to do
that and I'm doing it and I'm grateful
for it now I was going to say to talk
about our America and on the website at
our America initiative dot org dot com
com excuse me okay you talk about a
series of issues can we run through
those and just give us the one sentence
summary the economy well stop the
spending stop the spending common sense
look deficits deficits out of control
and and that's going to have a major
impact on all our lives strong dollar
rather than
weak dollar would you avoid it against
the tarp bailout absolutely and stimulus
package yes drugs drugs I think that we
should legalize marijuana of course when
you say legalize it's not a one-sentence
question Nick but when you talk about
legalizing marijuana looks never going
to be legal to smoke pot become impaired
get behind the wheel of a car never
going to be legal for kids to smoke a
pot but let's tax it let's regulate it
let's control it what do you see as the
effects of the drug war have had on the
country and and how much of that is a
pressing problem in your estimate well
half of what we spend on law enforcement
half what we spent in the courts and
half of what we spend on the prisons is
drug-related so by bringing about what I
will call rational drug policy by my
mirroring what we did with prohibition
which was to do away with prohibition
freeing up a lot of resources then for
real crime for four courts that can
actually disputes drug disputes that
would now get played out in courts
rather than with guns so it would make
this country a much better place
overnight you were one of the first
politicians or the first prominent
politician to stake out this position in
the United States describe a bit how
that played out in your political career
what was the ramifications of that are
usually the third line of cocaine on the
plate of American politics drug
legalization I found the issue to be
very thin ice I found the issue to be a
good issue that people really do
understand this with just a little bit
of knowledge and that that it is going
to change I believe that the issue right
now is that a tipping point nationally
we've had we've had vote in during the
last general election in massachusetts
to vote to decriminalize marijuana by a
vote of 65 235 wherever a medical
marijuana has been on the initiative
it's passed overwhelmingly gallup poll
just a couple of months ago suggest that
forty four percent of the population of
this country believes that marijuana
should be legal it's never been that
high
so again I found people armed with just
a little bit of knowledge on this topic
move move to a more rational position
who are your political heroes though you
know I had I thought I had a whole bunch
of them until I got involved in the
process and then I found out that there
just aren't principled individuals
involved in politics and not that I
didn't make a lot of really good
political friends and found a lot of
individuals to be very principled in in
what it is they've done for the most
part I've been disillusioned on on
political heroes back to this notion of
actually doing what you say you do
that's the rare breed and those are my
those are my yeah I mean do are we adult
enough of you know it's always it's kind
of stunning to think that we're ten
years into the 21st century are we
finally grown up enough where we don't
need political heroes or we don't need a
leader what we need is somebody who will
allow you know infinite number of
individuals to get on with things well
having the libertarian leanings that I
have and that would be based on I really
don't like to be told what to do you
know I understand what's right and wrong
and that doesn't necessarily always
equate to the law laws should be laws
should be common sense based and it
really do we need laws to tell us what's
right and wrong not not really fewer
laws more orderly society is but but
again we're moving in opposite direction
to that more and more laws dictating how
we should live our lives and one size
doesn't fit all is America ready for a
prominent politician who is scaled man
Everest is very when did you you climbed
Mount Everest you been to the top of the
world so left what year was that 2003
the left office and actually got to the
top of Mount Everest so it's all been
downhill son
it has been downhill from there no it
was a great experience it was fabulous
what what drove you to do that you know
I've got a goal to climb the highest
mountain on each continent in the world
I had the good fortune of doing four of
them and and barring some sort of a
catastrophic injury I will make it to
the top of all these summits there's no
rush to do it but I just thought that
would be a great way to see the planet
and again a fortunate enough to have
gotten to the top of four of them to
this point I'm Nick Gillespie for reason
TV with Matt Welch of Reason magazine we
want to thank the former new mexico
governor gary johnson currently with our
America initiative calm for talking to
reason TV today thanks Gary thank you
you